hey everyone it's sarah register nurse
rn.com and in this video we're going to
talk about frequency abbreviations
used to describe medication times and
orders
also whenever we get done watching this
youtube video you can access the free
quiz that will test you
on this material so let's get started
it's important to be familiar with
abbreviations that are used to describe
frequencies and frequencies refers to
the amount of times that something
should be completed or administered
for example frequency abbreviations and
nursing can be used to describe
how often a patient needs to take a
medication like do they need to take the
medication in the am or the pm
or q4h meaning every four hours or
bid which means twice a day or
abbreviations can be used when ordered
by the physician to tell the nurse
how often certain lab levels should be
drawn for example like troponin levels
the physician may order some troponin
levels
q6h which means every six hours
now you always want to be careful
whenever you are using abbreviations and
to follow the abbreviation guidelines
set by your employer
because some abbreviations can have
multiple meanings and it can lead to a
medical error
so if you're ever in doubt about an
abbreviation just simply write it out
the first one is ac and ac stands for
before meals now you may see this
abbreviation
along with either like breakfast lunch
or dinner
for example you may see ac and then
beside of it bk
and that would just simply mean before
breakfast
then we have the opposite of ac and it
is pc
and pc stands for after meals
so how do you keep these two straight
well we have
ac which means before meals and remember
in the alphabet a
comes before all of the other letters so
we know that's before
and then we have pc which is after meals
and p
comes after a now two other types of
abbreviations that you may see that's
similar to the before and after
frequency
is like an a with a line above it or a p
with a line above it
if you see it with an a and a line that
would mean before and a p with a line
would mean after and then we have the
abbreviation
p.m and p.m means in the evening so
around night time and then the opposite
of that is
am and this is four in the morning
now you may also encounter the
abbreviation hs
however it's really no longer
recommended because it can be confused
with half
strength and it would represent bedtime
but they really recommend that you write
out the word bedtime instead of using
hs next we have the letter q and you may
see this as a capital q or a lowercase q
and this means every also hr
or just h and that means hour and then
min m-i-n which stands for minutes
and many times these abbreviations are
combined with a number
to specify the frequency for instance
you may see
q2hr or q2h and that stands for every
two hours
and you can keep going like every four
hours every six hours and this is a
popular way
of how many medications are administered
and then you may also
see it as q15 men which would mean like
every 15 minutes and this is a popular
way
for how we dictate how we're going to
collect vital signs for like let's say a
post-op patient
then we have the frequency daily and
this could just be written out
daily or it could be written out as q 24
hr or q24h
and this is just something to describe
that whatever needs to be
given or done daily now back in the day
they used to
use the abbreviation q d however that
is a one that you absolutely do not use
it's no longer recommended in practice
then we have the frequency every other
day and there is no abbreviation
approved for this one
they recommend that you just write that
out back in the day
again they used to use qod for every
other day but that is no longer
recommended in practice
next we have the abbreviation bid and
this stands for
twice a day you may also see tid and
that stands for three times a day
and then qid which stands for four times
a day
and these abbreviations are actually
latin
terms that they've used to abbreviate
and lastly let's look at these
miscellaneous frequency abbreviations so
the first one is stat
s-t-a-t and this means immediately so it
is
time critical then we have the letter x
and x means
time or time so for example you may see
a
x x1 and that would mean one time
or one dose only for example let's say
you get an order for
morphine it may say give morphine iv
two milligrams um x1
times one dose and there's also add
lib and that means as much as the
patient desires i have seen this
abbreviation
whenever the physician's ordering the
patient to be up out of bed like
oob out of bed or to ambulate like
ambulate as much as the patient desires
and lastly we have
prn which means as needed so a lot of
times you're going to see this
with some medication orders so the
medication order may say the patient can
have a certain medication
prn as needed for pain like q4h
which would mean every four hours now
let's quickly test your knowledge on
these frequency abbreviations
so you see the abbreviation ac what does
that mean
it means before meals so if you've seen
that you needed to give a medication ac
you would need to give it before meals
next is tid
pc so if you've seen this what does it
mean to you
it means that you need to do it three
times a day
after meals so now let's say you have a
patient who's taken an oral medication
and they're taking it q6h
how many doses is that patient receiving
per day
well we know that q6h or q6hr means
every six hours so we know there's 24
hours in a day
so that patient is getting four doses
per day
okay if you would like some more
practice with these abbreviations you
can access the free quiz and the link
below
and don't forget to check out the other
videos in this abbreviation
series